nous sommes
[Musique]
dix mille euros par mois de maintenance e
maintenant nous devons essayer de l'empêcher de
faire un musée ou un château du dimanche
de votre propre alors nous ne vendons pas le vôtre
mémoire et qu'ils m'ont mis en prison oui
tout change d'avantage depuis ambola et
souffrir reste encore un parfum
[Musique]
Je me sens bien sans un homme sans
des enfants sans travail qui vous oblige
élevé pour mériter a un emploi et s'il y a
Disons
il me semblait que
car je peux donner ma vie
hier de jésus christ ça dépend de
jours mais avouons-le je ne pense pas que
est tombée enceinte d'esprit saint
dommage au fait le sexe aime pas
juste manger sur edison
ils citent compter les faveurs avec de rossi mais
le temps de ne pas voir juste avant de naples
vers elle terrifiée sur-le-champ
pâlit puis puis puis
très alarmé sur blanc ce
occasion sont cette poupée